oh i guess while you get your medicine
i'll just stroll through the candy
aisles but won't get any you can buy two
candies
two can i help you i have the flu
super nauseated for a few days a lot of
barfing
it's a total disaster plus i have a ton
of work to do so i need the good stuff
the mariah needs to sing tonight
stuff you don't look flushed no
signs of fever that doesn't seem like
the flu it's the flu
i mean i don't think it could be
anything
hello andrew what's new um
a whole lot check this out i just
invented it
super straw
so just sit here and do your thing
do i have to tuck my shirt in because
honestly that's kind of a deal-breaker
let her fly hey wait where's april
is she all right yeah i just gave her
the day off would it be weird if i asked
for the day off yeah no
it's okay i didn't think so
[Music]
ron swanson's office
yes i will transfer you
i just dropped another call
leslie go home no i can't i can't go
home i have to get ready for the chamber
of secrets
commerce if this meeting does not go
perfectly then the harvest festival is
going to be over before it began i
cannot go home
okay then who is your doctor anne's my
doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world come on
oh girl now i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster i had to also i had a
banana on the way over here
sorry i get why you don't want anyone to
know about duke silver and you don't
have to worry
your secret is safe with me to even it
out
i'm gonna tell you all of my secrets oh
no that's
not necessary i once forgot to brush my
teeth for five weeks
i didn't actually sell my last car i
just forgot where i parked it i don't
know who al gore is and at this point
i'm too afraid to ask
when they say two percent milk i don't
know what the other 98
is when i was a baby my head was so big
scientists did experiments on me i once
threw a beer at a swan
and then it attacked my niece rebecca
that'll do andrew
you don't have to play the unity concert
but don't quit music
please
first things first oven mitts where are
the oven mitts
oh my god they have all the as seen on
tv stuff
oh shake weight iron gym miracle hand
repair big top cookie
pillow pets slap chop honey we got to go
over here honey
listen to me get it all
grab everything that we've seen it on tv
put it in this cart right now
iron gym i am going to get so bummed i
got a fire smell shooter marshmallow
shooter
wait what about the magic bullet yeah
i've seen that
mighty putty
what are we doing we didn't get a single
thing that ben told us too
sure we did we got the marshmallow
shooter
i don't think that's on the list but i
want it i want it too
but i also kind of want my own fork just
cause you eat really slow which is cute
but also
super annoying
fine what what's wrong nothing it's just
adults are boring and i hate them and i
don't want to buy all this stupid boring
adult stuff and become boring adults
hey listen to me yes we're gonna get a
dish rack and
shower curtains and a cutting board but
if you think for one second i'm not also
gonna get that marshmallow shooter
so that i can shoot you in the face with
marshmallows when you're asleep then
you're the dumbest woman i know
you're gonna make me cry
hey ron can i ask you kind of an
important question
you know like when you go to the atm and
you get money is there an actual guy
standing behind the wall who slides
dollar bills in there
no yeah this is robots oh actually you
know what i do have a serious question
in a movie predator
can you rub any kind of mud on yourself
to prevent predator from seeing you with
this thermal heat signature site or is
it
one ow that sucks are you hurt
oh no all good all good
oops except for my mouth
oh whoa five second rule
no uh the receptionist says she'll fit
you in as soon as there's an opening
if you're all right i'm going to head
back to the park
do you know what my social security
number is or
if i'm allergic to anything i don't like
corn should i put that down
or will that be confusing because i do
like candy corn
oh ron what a mess
here let me help you all i wanted was
two hours where i got to forget that i
was
a parent all right look i found all
three differences
those are two completely different
pictures
i've started interviewing people to fill
in for leslie i have found
five candidates i'd like to hire and two
i'd like to be lifelong friends with
well you will not be hiring anyone
because my department is just finishing
up a major project
excuse me everything i'm wearing is
suede everything i'm wearing is suede
everything excuse me everybody attention
i think you'll agree that this
department could use a little leadership
it's a kamikaze
look to the left all right
whatever are you the kind of doctor who
gets hooked on his own drugs
i bet you are so handy tell me what
happened i was reading
an encyclopedia and i tripped or fell
over and hit my head or brain helmet
you call it yeah he sneezed and smacked
his head against the wall
that sounds about right well if it's a
concussion it's extremely mild so i
wouldn't worry about it
anything else bothering you nope okay
well i mean yeah i've got a weird uh
rash in my knee pit area and my tongue
on this side
doesn't taste anything anymore sometimes
when i walk my ankles make like a weird
rattle
snake sound what else things that are
far away from my eyes
are fuzzy i once ate a twix with the
wrapper on it
and i've never seen the wrapper come out
also i've swallowed every piece of gum
that i've chewed for the past 25 years
i don't know it broke my thumb on the
way over here it just
fixed me well i can help you with a
thumb and i'll have to give you
referrals for
specialists for the other thousand
things wow thanks for nothing dr harris
you're welcome and your pawnee high prom
king and queen are lucy
taylor and andy dwyer
what i broke the box and i threw away
all the votes and i voted for you a
thousand times
you should get on up there king dwyer
not without my queen
hi pawnee hi as your prom king i am your
ruler
silence my first decree of power
is to declare that the prom queen
shall be my wife april ludgate who is
the best thing that's ever happened to
me who came to prom even though she
hates it
give me this always next year no there
isn't i'm a senior
this is your wife how old are you he's
33 and i'm 47 slash immortal
get out leslie i don't know what to tell
you i don't i don't think he did it
yeah he did and we need a confession
okay andy and i are going to take a walk
and it's gonna be just you pocatus and
these pliers
look i'm not gonna torture this kid
nobody said torture
why don't you let me take a run at him
boss in order to think
like one of these guys you have to think
like them yeah
he's never seen you before so imply that
you're someone very important
and that you can make his life hell
greg pochitas would you like some
boiling hot
coffee your face
my name is bert macklin yeah i'm with
the
fbi
[Music]
huh looks like andy's wearing him down
i'm gonna go finish him off
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard don't you just shut up for a
second
what's going on he's he's a jerk he's
being such a
jerk it's an awful thing to say to a
human being are you crying no i'm i'm
not crying okay
i'm allergic to jerks okay andy out
here
you